consider the following notion snake oil
to the cynic is often holy water to the
eager what does this tell us
right the obvious thing of course is
that our interpretive framework govern
our experience of reality how we
perceive things our lenses of
perceptions disclose the kind of
experience that we are going to have so
again the cynic sees everything like a
drag the cynic sees everything has
dreary
infused with the finality of every day
his lenses of perception pollute taped
his experience of the optimist sees
bliss and possibility
everywhere he looks optimist dwells
mounted potential the optimist dares to
conceive of what might be and through
his actions potentiates ideas into being
the optimist ends up as a kind of
sorcerer as a kind of Dream Weaver as a
kind of alchemist that concocts and
creates the cynic shuns the world with a
defeatist despair living what Dostoevsky
refers to as a quiet life of desperation
we all know the type
but as McKenna said you are the some of
the people you spend the most amount of
time with us so if you wish to take
control to take agency over your lenses
of perception curate your life be
discerning in your choices you're
creative in the worst of choices govern
your fate something I've repeatedly said
before we see with our lenses we see
through our lenses but we often don't
see the lenses themselves and the lenses
themselves my friends we have agency we
can swap them out we can construct two
lenses we can italicize our perception
we can overcome the pimpare and esteem
that of the adults we can awaken the
mind reduction the electorate of custom
and the film of familiarity and redirect
them towards the wonders of existence we
can sing the songs that orchestrate the
universe we can hack this
[Music]
just got to make it happen